whatever camera you're using if it's not
this it's probably not as good there are
only four lights that you need to know
about to shoot videos oh youtube's like
oh we recommend you watch this corridor
crew video just admit that you need to
subscribe
some of you watching this video may want
to make movies and videos yourselves but
when you look at what people are using
in the pro league it can look super
intimidating you know what you don't
need that our gear is specifically
tailored to let us get the best possible
image but with a group that is small
nimble and lets us shoot in an
affordable way
anyways i don't know if you're
interested in this stuff or not but uh
we're going to tell you
all right the first thing to talk about
is the camera there's a lot of different
cameras out there and honestly at this
point they're pretty much all good the
red camera this is where it all starts
why is it the best two things really
quick i can screw it up on set i can
miss my exposure i can
almost soar there do everything wrong
except for focus let's be changed all
that after the fact this is generally
called a raw format red has a raw format
that is compressed is small and is very
versatile second of all it's high bit
depth means when we apply filters to
this footage it doesn't destroy it
doesn't tear it apart and look all gross
and blocky we use this because when we
color grade our footage we want it to
look nice i'm just saying there's a
reason i'm not saying like the a7 is
better
it's because it's not
we're working our way out after your
camera the lenses are the next most
important thing and we've been using the
sigma art series lenses for a few months
now almost a year they're the best
they're basically if i had to describe
them i would describe them as high res
because simply they're so crisp and
clear they allow you to actually
maximize the resolution of whatever
camera you're shooting on these lenses
are great they are the best lenses i
have ever used plan on using them into
the future these little things all right
third most important thing when it comes
to your camera we have filters here
which are quite nice we've been using
the tiffin filters for a long time
really really good really high quality
high enough quality to not make my
sigmas look bad sam is the audio guy
here
in fact he was the audio guy back before
we even had a youtube channel and you
were using this microphone should i plug
it in so we can hear it no
you can hear it in every single corridor
video that's on our channel i love
sennheiser mics but we have a trusty
standby it's the audio technica at897
anyways great mic highly recommended i
love sennheiser gear we had a sennheiser
microphone go bad on us so sad what's
that but their headphones are great
we've actually been using the wireless
pxc 550 wireless noise canceling
bluetooth headphones they're super cool
they're super comfy they're great for
planes they're great for sets and also
they're really really good for working
in an office environment that helps me
get my work done when others are trying
to stop me i do half of my hearing
through these headphones and the noise
cancelling it's so good that it scares
me it makes the world so silent you can
hear your own brain promising but flawed
camera manufacturers are gonna realize
that we are in the year 2019 and they
can put a dang bluetooth chip in their
cameras so i can monitor the audio
without a freaking wire going between me
and my camera multiple bluetooth outputs
would be great so everybody can be
listening to it guys
that's what i feel like on set the
sennheiser g3 system wireless audio been
great little pack here for the back of
our boom mic this wireless system we've
been using since day one there's just
simply limits to the technology such as
uh it's a radio it's the year 2018 and
we're using radios
radio transmission sometimes the signal
gets a little weak it's a little janky
well they fixed it in the g4 which is
the upgraded version of this we should
probably upgrade as you can see by the
scratches the more scratches you see on
the equipment you mean that means it's
good
this table guys
okay speaking of camera stuff and
wireless technology let's talk about
monitoring this here is a small hd
monitor on a noodle of a rig ignore the
rig small hd makes great monitors the
really cool thing about them is that you
can actually apply filters to your
footage in the modder itself so you can
see what it looks like when it's in its
final colored state and this is paired
with the nereus hd wireless bridge this
lets us have a wireless signal from the
camera to the small hd but you know what
you don't need that anymore these days
because small hd now has it built into
their monitors if you go to their site
you can check it out why use cables
well cables are super reliable just
imagine that you're shooting something
with more than one person imagine a
world where you're filming something and
someone else has to see what's being
filmed at the same time what about what
about professional cameras we're going
you're a pro but you're on the go
gopro cameras super over-engineered
these days i hate to say it one out of
two of them break except for the
sessions the sessions are the promise of
what the gopro thought it could be the
session gets our hearty endorsement for
the best action camera 100 100 1
hundreds hey how are you going to film
your scene if it's too dark
there are only four lights that you need
to know about to shoot videos only four
and we're gonna tell you what they are
right now light number one a panel light
this is the best panel light on the
market this is the light panels astra it
gets really bright it lets you change
colors between tungsten and daylight
also the ballast is attached to the
light so it's all in one package
convenient and horrible number two the
120 series from aperture so these
aperture led lights are really nice and
they do something that the astra does
not which is focus the light they have
these fresnel lenses attached to them
incredible these things are precise they
give you nice clean clean shadows these
are on every single set now there's
other things we need out of lights
though one thing is color
and these are some really funny little
lights these are the luxely cello lights
and these things run off of little sony
batteries but what's incredible is that
they can go across the entire color
spectrum that moth video that we just
released i use this light and it's a
little baby cousin version for nearly
every single shot there's one final
light
that you need to be aware of i
legitimately don't know which light
sam's going to point out the fourth and
final light
fits in the palm of my hand
oh cool
these guys
all right these are the m9s from
aperture they have a slightly bigger
brother but these things
i love these things every single shot
you see on this youtube channel
has one of these m9s right next to the
lens yeah let's talk about batteries
with real big batteries macho batteries
like this so we have anton bauer
batteries there's also other batteries
we have as well because these are
basically giant power banks that can
power anything from a light to your
camera to your monitor to anything else
and have it last for multiple hours you
can even charge your phone because they
have usb ports on them
modern technology wow what good is all
this gear if you have no way to hold it
up right we don't just set our cameras
on the ground do we again we come back
to this rubber limited rubbermaid
lifetime
uh
table quarter digital dot store
everybody's a good tripod for the gear
this is a sackler tripod i don't need
fuss i don't need must i just need an
easy efficient system that can do with
one person once again
just look at the wear and tear on this
thing
that means it's a good product i'm not
going to show you how it works or show
it in use but zun cranes the iu don't
use gimbals too frequently anymore but
when we do
uh the zhiyun cranes are really really
nice there's a lot of really crappy
handheld gimbals on the market but the
zhiyun cranes are not one of them put
the camera on there you turn it on and
it works so the new ronin-s
haven't really used it too much looks
really good maybe we'll upgrade to it we
do have other gimbals they stay in the
closet let's go old school here and this
is too big to set up so we left it in
the closet but this is where chromical
cuts the b-roll of us using this we
found sliders are for chumps the liebeck
jib arm and track by far the best thing
you can get if you want smooth versatile
camera motion or cinematic movements
this is better than any gimbal it's
better than any tripod by itself this is
better than any slider it makes all
these things obsolete it is rock solid
it's super basic technology and it will
never let you down computer time let's
talk about let's talk about electronics
all right so there's computers there's
good computers and bad computers
generally computers that you build
yourself fall into the good computers
and what's even better than self-built
computers are the ones we have from
puget systems they are our most powerful
computers in the studio they are the
workhorses that do a lot of our editing
and rendering and all the cool
processing the thing is those guys are
really good at outfitting them and
they're really good at helping us out
with little customer support issues when
there are
issues which is very rarely those are
really really good tell me about origin
i know
there's a reason we're working with
puget now instead of origin
corridors 2018 here video
we would be remiss not to grab the
camera and turn it around these boys oh
hi
they do more filming than we do get over
here you need to wear these so that way
the microphone doesn't break on you and
you don't know
a video micro
by rode really great really small
phantom powered by dslr sound quality
passable cheap 70 bucks this tripod but
benro
i don't remember the actual model but
it's a travel one the shitty part about
these kind of tripods is you can't level
the head you always have to
like adjust the leg to get it the best
thing about benro is they've solved that
problem for every single model some type
of micro bowl head at the top to just
adjust it right there
i can just
now it's spiked ready for grass
now it's ready for your uh living room
or kitchen piece of gear i swear by is
this little fish that sam printed me
to hold all the memory cards guys guys
guys guys guys i forgot to mention this
3d printing pretty handy and you want to
get into 3d printing matterhackers other
guys to go to if you want to get one
ultimaker 3 brought me into the 3d
printing game when previously i was like
i did not have the time to learn how to
do it so nico oh that the sigma lens oh
this whole thing this whole thing the
thing that you're holding as well yeah
we shoot everything on these they're the
adds canon 80ds 1080p
60 frames per second now we're shooting
60 frames but we edit and release in 30
frames per second it doesn't matter if
you have the best camera it matters that
you know what camera you're using you
may also use that camera for longer if
you have a battery extender which we
it's so great it's cam oh it's a canon
one no wait
canons is 300 this is a 70 one from
amazon yeah this feels so small now 10
to 20 because wide lenses are amazing
and we want fancy shots we use this 18
to 35 1.8 sigma or we just grab a macro
lens from the corridor case
little lights as you saw on top some
sort of janky rig that changes every
couple the one the one on that camera is
way better you can see it now it's
amazing ads that's the best camera
out there
for what for one yeah kind of michael
what is your favorite question here
the capture and the lens kit that might
not make sense what i just said it's a
great choice it's called it's
technically just a lens holster peak
designs capture and then lens kit
they're two separate products you but
they can be used together
let's take actually
let's do a full spin we'll spin give me
the most expensive lens we have no belts
i'm gonna tighten this up thousand
dollar lens on this
i'm gonna put it on my belt you're crazy
this little button allows me to take it
off otherwise it'd be there now safety
lock it by twisting it it's a hot swap
it's a hot swap
normally i'd have to use this tape i'm
not going to use the table
[Music]
ready for the next shot boss
i have never felt like i want to keep
swapping lenses more
boom i like red bull too pretty amazing
um you can have more than one heck
uh well yes we do
so i just want to put this camera away
see if it can work come on
this is just a
if you go to a wedding and you look at
any of the photographers this is how a
photographer looks yeah a little bit
more defeated yeah that's about it
all right i hope you enjoyed our little
gear review with attitude here we'll
have some links to it in the description
below it's all about the same thing it's
about finding gear that allows you to
just do what you want to do in less time
less headaches and just i want to shoot
a scene well let's just go shoot that
scene come on come on stop letting
youtube recommend your videos and start
subscribing to them and making decisions
for yourself there are links to all this
gear in the description below so go
check it out if you want any of this for
yourself also we included a couple links
to things that we didn't have time to
talk about in this video but still worth
checking out like the ktek boom pole
it's wonderful
it's long enough for me to touch the top
of sam's head sorry the touch the front
of sam's body
22 or three feet